la dics mjc il faut est dans la tête de
kenji bhl qui a vu dans la tête de john
malkovich oui oui c'est pareil assure
que sa télé c'est pas un film et ça dure
beaucoup moins longtemps on a posé des
questions à kenji sur lui sur son
univers sur sa vie sur son talent fou
kay gee a répondu nous a donné ces
réponses vous allez jouer également
il ya pas une petite pancarte une petite
ardoise pour valérie et fils merci on en
a une sinon vous allez chez plein ciel
juste à côté c'est juste à côté une
chute
merci merci philippe pas mal à trouver
vous a donné et kenji confirmera ou pas
je vous posais des questions sur kadji
vous répondez ce que vous pensez
d'accord la battre and seek mg j devait
se faire un tatouage quels motifs ferait
thil et ou d'accords quel motif leur est
il est où
pour réfléchissez vous répondez vite à
votre avis et qu elle dit nous a
vraiment répondu vous allez savoir ce
qu'ils feraient s'ils kenji devait se
faire un tatouage qu'elle motyl ferait
il est où
alors attention heures dans les
questions naturelles d'un mois mathieu
écoutez ça va
non mais qui sait
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi on trouvera les coupables
n'étaient pas vides dans le dos une [ __ ]
la vo
non mais ben oui mais bon ça va mon
corps oui disposer du bon d'accord et
quoi commence à quoi et où sa house
ces bons ne me regarde pas moi tu as dit
mais non mais non qu'est-ce que tu te
ferais tu as tout ils ont corps ah oui
c'est vrai oui et laura et j'en avais
même idée votre tête dans le dos ouais
ouais et sa maman près du coeur
d'accord la maman c'est mignon c'est
mignon vous une guitare sur les fesses
d'accord une couverture de télé 7 jours
c'est marrant vous feriez se paye la
tête d'edf sur la fesse droite à l'ailé
c'est plus qu'à égale à e s dé donc si
riche kenji galoche d amour éternel ont
dit vrai et sur le coeur et le fraysse
et ça fera mal vos mets bogdanov avec
une guitare une caravane sur les fesses
et une roulotte sur les fans vont
bientôt la bonne réponse et moi la bonne
réponse ben c'est une étoile je pense
non non une note de musique note et je
voulais voir dominique je vous donner un
avis c'est la nôtre est
c'est alors attention
quel était le surnom de kenji lorsqu'il
était enfant oui génération ou pas c'est
vrai qu'il grattait des plus tout à
l'heure il me pense tout plein de
questions alors il va ne lui répondait
pas aux séries il a l'habitude alors
qu'elle était le surnom kenji valérie
bénaïm kelly kelly d'eau qui veut dire
mon chéri mon chéri kenny do vous l'avez
pris pour un chocolat ou un thierry
moreau athènes d'accord j'ai remarqué
que nos sites elle aussi valérie kenji
joue quasi joue assez marqué quand j'ai
su aussitôt dit aussi je suis désolé je
croyais que déjà que kenji station ne
sais pas c'est quoi livrer votre vrai
nom un prénom
ouais c'est angie c'est qu'est jean
cheymol d'accord combien d'heures
chicken jean lamy jiji je crois que
c'est parce que moi je les lui je crois
que c'est la bonne réponse creed
allemand c'est pour ça qu'il a appelé
son album comme ça parce que petit c'est
est ce qu'on va en parler dans le
restaurant quoi parce que tu es tu
d'accord très bien merci zizou kenji
excusez moi et on fait une émission
alors qu'hadji à kenji mjg d'accord eh
bien non c'était quoi votre surnom quand
vous étiez enfant et matthieu delormeau
l'a dit un s'écrit tanoh parce qu'en
fait quand vous étiez petit c'est ce que
vous avez lu dans l'album voilà c'est
une énorme connerie c'est pas du tout ça
c'est quoi votre sur doc hadji c'est ma
mère qui m'a appelé comme ça c'est quoi
un moment je vais dire papillon papillon
mignon bas et on a des points communs
parce que vous étiez dans l'air elle
vous appelez papillon mois à m'appeller
cafard jamais on n'aurait pu se croiser
j'avais essayé je me rends le compte
d'une chose dans cette que cette
séquence en fait je suis pas sûr que les
ardoises ça sert à quelque chose non il
vaut mieux le dire à l'oral comme ça
c'est beaucoup moins longs c'est
beaucoup plus sympa hormis chanteur quel
métier aurait-il rêvé de faire étant
plus jeune à votre avis valérie kenji
quand il était petit oui pas comédien
comédiens fils de garagiste julia quand
ils étaient plus jeunes noyellois
quand il était plus jeune et il était
pas né votre valérie pilote de course
bout ouais je le vois dans l'âme ou de
touche pendant la moto danseurs danseurs
coureur cycliste au dresseur de chevaux
et leurs astronautes
non mais moi je suis persuadé que ça
aussi mais je crois que c'est non
mais non mais comme j'ai lu avant de
préparer l'émission j'ai dû me tromper
mais dont je crois qu'effectivement
c'est sport automobile et la raison est
vrai pilote automobile
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
la dernière question quel est le pire
tue l'amour pour kenji checkdo nombreux
jeunes filles qui nourrira qui se
demandent quel est le pire tue l'amour
pour kenji garbez le manque d'hygiène
vous isabelle chésa et laura je sais pas
des grosses de jean sérien voyez vous à
lettres des grandes dents mathieu les
poils
excusez moi lui maintenant il fait la
tête 2 0 la nouvelle tête qu'on fait
étrange aurait fait six années passées
fait le bas c'est un mélange trop de de
niro et bourvil dans cette saison gérard
même annonçant qu est-ce que oui ou vase
à l'aide oui que la fille garde ses
chaussettes peut-être non valérie des
pieds dégueulasse seeking joue de la
guitare autour du nom fils une belle
guen couleur chair d'accord et vous
valérie des poils sournois tête way une
mauvaise haleine mauvaise hygiène et ça
m'a fait beaucoup de mal quand j'ai
appris ça le cuir tue l'amour pour kenji
c'est les poils j'ai dit on s'en fout on
voit qu'il est entrain de m'attaquer
personnellement mais on s'étreint garçon
s'est imposé des poids lourds mais ces
choix seront à saisir comment ça j'ai un
garçon commence à chaud gars sont à
priori vous avez un zizi est-ce que vous
avez un 10/10 je n'ai plus mon et
ciblées
aux leçons de mathieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
c'est bon on l'a vu on l'a vu jc des
poils un ouais on n'est pas les poils
sur une femme célèbre et moi je me
rappelle moi je suis sorti avec une
femme serait elle avait des poils
partout partout partout quand on se
baigner je me rappelle les gens disaient
oh maman je vais pas me baigner à plein
d'algues
olic a failli
[Musique]